[Music]
there are certain things we see every
day and never give a second thought
about their history but with a little
digging the evolution of everyday
objects can be shocking if you are a
first-time viewer click the red
subscribe button and enjoy today
we are revealing 10 regular objects that
look nothing like they used to
sunglasses before people were using
their sunglasses to look cool indoors
they actually served a purpose these are
the oldest pair of sunglasses ever found
and believed to be 800 years old they
were designed by Inuit
to help protect their eyes from the
light that reflected off the ice and
snow the light from the snow could get
so dangerous that it could actually
blind people thankfully we have a much
more attractive way to keep the Sun out
and look cool at the same time these
metal keys have certainly evolved over
the years but are quickly becoming
obsolete thanks to technology the first
versions of metal keys were simpler than
what we see today and since having
something worth lucky enough was
uncommon in the ancient times having the
key became more of a status symbol than
anything else these days people have so
many keys they can't keep up with them
not to mention the hundreds of hotel key
cards they probably have lying around
toilet paper
could you imagine wiping your bottom
with a rock well that's exactly what
scientists think a few ceramic discs
were used for it is believed that
ancient Romans use hard sponges dipped
in vinegar on a stick to clean up after
using the restroom but because many of
these ceramic discs have been unearthed
in several Greek and Roman Lateran it's
an easy conclusion that they were also
used as ancient toilet paper thankfully
there have been many advances in this
department high hills high hills first
popped up in history around 3500 BC and
they have made several transformation
since these pair of hills from ancient
Roman Greece were known as buskin and
were worn by stage performers to help
differentiate the social class of
individual characters in the Middle Ages
high hills made of wood known as patents
were slipped on so Nobles to keep their
expensive shoes clean of mud and street
litter these days high heels were worn
by men
women who wish to spice up an outfit
with a still tree Footwear map
considering hundreds of years ago many
believe the world was flat it shouldn't
be surprising that map was completely
different this first injury map shows an
earth that has much more land than water
and the Americas aren't even on it it
wasn't until the late 1600s that we see
a map that is closer to the ones we use
today
in modern times we don't even use paper
map most of the time we rely on our cell
phones to tell us where to go
cars one of the first cars to hit the
road was this one point one horsepower
carriage that was invented in 1886 just
look at the difference in style and a
difference in horsepower to what we see
today
this car featured three tires and a rear
engine and apparently they believed a
six was the best way to steer the car
has evolved so much that now 130 years
later we have over 500 times more
horsepower and luckily for us a steering
wheel Apple computers in 1976 one of the
world's now most famous and lucrative
tech companies was born Apple and their
first product was the Apple 1 computer
it looks like something a kid could
throw together at their local high
school but it was considered a huge
technological advancement back in the
70s
thanks to Steve Wozniak and Steve Jobs
innovation we now have iPhones and Mac's
books that put the early Apple computer
to shame stock these days most people
wouldn't be caught dead wearing socks
with sandals but that wasn't the case 16
hundred years ago in fact these ancient
woolen socks were made by the Egyptians
to specifically wear with sandals
considering there probably weren't many
Footwear choices in 400 AD we can
forgive the ancient Egyptians for this
fashion faux-pas bra there is nothing
about the words breast-conscious that
sounds appealing but this is what bras
were made of hundreds of years ago this
bra from Austria is thought to be around
five hundred years old
notice the pouch-like shape and the lack
of underwire and there doesn't seem to
be any adjusting straps which means this
bra was custom made for its owner bras
in modern times are still considered
torture devices much like this one
probably was but it
lycée are much more attractive condoms
we often hear of the crazy ways people
used to prevent birth before condoms
were invented but we don't often hear
about what these original condoms were
made from or what they look like that is
until now this reusable condom is around
370 years old and is made from sheep
skin it looks terrifying and not
pleasurable at all the instructions have
been preserved and call for it to be
cleaned with warm milk to prevent
venereal disease - yikes are you happy
that these regular objects looks nothing
like they used to react in the comments
section below and don't forget to like
this video and subscribe to the things
[Music]
hmm